so for the next 20 or so minutes
I thought it would be a fun exercise
The Prompt at GPT
and try and have it make new chess
openings
and then to play them
in the hourly super Blitz and try and
win the tournament with a brand new
opening repertoire and I'll probably
take suggestions for prompts from chat
in one of the openings after me haha
okay so invent a new chess opening
named I eat Play-Doh
[Music]
oh no
oh okay we can't promote eating Play-Doh
okay what about please invent a chess
opening named after a healthy fruit or
vegetable
okay
the broccoli Bishop wait what I like how
every move is a broccoli variation
wait wait wait wait wait the broccoli
Bishop
E4 E5 this is a Bishop's opening
but maybe it's a healthier version Queen
H5
Knight F6 Queen F7
in D7 is not legal because it's
checkmate
oh it's so healthy
banana opening
what's a banana
oh the banana
actually banana is actually a real
opening
the banana is just B3 let's say black
just plays like a London setup A3
Knight F3
A4
Knight C3
and then A5 and this would be the banana
because it spells b-a-n-a-n-a
okay let's see if we can get it to like
actually come up with um a real opening
suggest a very rare chess opening
with a funny name for me to play in
Blitz chaos the Hungry Hungry Hippo
wait this is just a wayward Queen attack
oh
I guess it's a hungrier version of the
real hippo any opening it spits out even
if it's like a real opening I'll try and
play it in the upcoming tournament
so
Knight C6 Bishop C4 G6 Queen F3 Knight
F6
92 Bishop G7 D3 D6
okay
and why it hasn't like consumed anything
in these moves
so maybe that's why white is hungry
ask for gambits okay provide me with a
complete Gambit repertoire
the play in an upcoming Blitz ornament
be sure to include lots of openings with
clicks and traps okay
it's not really inventing new openings
but at least it's giving me some decent
recommendations here
we got some of the the classic gambits
so what do we have we have the Danish
Gambit
this is a full Danish Gambit
completely
I don't know if it will like agree to
answer that it's gonna say that probably
the prompt is unethical yeah this is
really just an experimental stream
um we have the Kings Gambit
oh but it gives some okay give some
specific Lion King's gonna be accepted
the more Gambit
which is this
X here here it takes
the binko Gambit which is for Black
after this this
is this
I haven't played that one in a while
blackmar Diemer Gambit
which is this one
could be a fun one I like how it
included Mora Gambit and Smith Maury
Gambit
the stats in Gambit
wait what
yeah it doesn't fully know like the
correct names uh this is this is
actually the Rosso Gambit
right
yeah this is a Riso the Statin is D4 F5
E4
and then the Wind Gap wait Wing Gambit
against E5
this is a fried liver
oh no this is the olvistad this is the
olvistad variation
I forgot about this opening it's
actually
um
the Overstock could be fun to play okay
these create a brand new chess Gambit
that has never been seen before and and
name it
after an animal
the penguin Gambit why do I feel like
this has been seen before
[Music]
so E4 E5 D4 so it starts out as a Danish
but we don't play the Danish we play
this
and then we play this
which is a Goring Gambit
what makes it the penguin gamut
Bishop B2 D6 Castle Bishop E6
we sack upon for quick development the
name penguin gamut is inspired by the
image of penguins sliding on the ice
which suggests the idea of quick and
fluid movement
I actually like the comparison
it's very poetic
it kind of looks like a penguin
please invent the goose Gambit
it should
be a completely novel series of opening
moves that have never been played before
what are we gonna get goo scanned it
I feel like we're making progress
oh wow this is thorough
you're here Knight C3 Knight F6 G3
it doesn't have a name on leechas
I thought this was called the the gleck
variation
there's like a famous player named
galact that used to play this
this is actually a cool one but how does
it relate to a goose
wait this doesn't make sense
develop the bishop while retaining the
flexibility of the D2 Knight yeah it's a
little bit confused about some specifics
but the continuation I think makes sense
takes takes
Bishop G2 and this has all been seen
before
I think there's a kramnik
was there a crown the game
yeah kramnik played this from the lock
side
so Bishop D6
Castle
D4 Ed for CD4 Bishop G4
alternatively black can challenge
with four F5
that's not legal though maybe in this
position 3f5 is legal the nabe is
inspired by the image of geese flying in
a V formation
not sure where our v formation is
but I still like the analogy
okay please invent
the Eric Rosen Gambit
it should embody all the wisdom of Eric
Rosen
ooh
seven H4 okay what is this gonna be
d4d5
it's a Queen's Gambit declined it's an
opening I like to play from the lock
side
um not quite a Cambridge Springs
Castle Knight F3
H6 H4 wow
novelty
in the Master's database
it's kind of like a fishing pole trap
this has been played at just over 8 000
times on me chess
now the big question is how bad is this
I mean there's takes takes we do have
the H file
the playable
okay only minus 1.3
I feel like this is the best thing it's
come up with so far
like something pretty new
it's better than the Stafford yeah the
staffer is like plus two in the
opponent's favor
black has to play 94 which is the most
played move
97 is already better for white due to G6
fg6 and Bishop D3 wow
a high win rate too
and if Knight E4
this really isn't that bad for white
according to the engine Bishop D3
and we're down the piece but engine only
gives slightly better for black
most people take on G5 which is the best
move
oh it gives more analysis too it
actually shares this line
it says Knight takes E4
94 de495
okay black can crush with Bishop B4 sack
but it gives this line
green H5 Bishop here Knight G4
I wonder how it's coming up with this
you're here
some deep analysis
I mean weights down a piece
as White's given up a Pawn Yeah it kind
of Strays away from the truth
at the very end
that's completely losing for white
I like the start of it though
if you're just joining I just asked chat
GPT to generate some new openings
so
now it's time to put these gamuts to the
test
here's a tournament
okay I've joined soul ties in chat so if
you're watching maybe you can allow me
to play the Eric Rose and Gambit in the
first game
oh okay
there we go
good luck Soul tie
wait what were the moves again
it starts with the Queen's gamma
declined this is a rated Blitz game too
we have a close score
uh was it E3 I think it's nine of three
I think the moves are interchangeable
though
it's 903 E3 and then H4
oh dear
okay let's go we have the Eric Rosen
Gambit invented by chat CPT
this is so exciting it just analyzes
now it wanted takes in 95 but that
that's not good because of Bishop B4 so
we're gonna
add some twists to this bishop D3 I
think is the best move
and the engine only gave like minus 0.6
getting the early time advantage
I don't remember like the further
analysis though I just know that the
queen wants to come
h8 or H7
life goals
C5 wow
okay this already looks like very
appealing
or does it G6 is a good move
play Queen C2
there's also 95 probably 95.
maybe now Queen C2
okay I'm telling a piece but I have most
of my things aiming at the king side
this Pawn is kind of hanging
my intention is to sacrifice another
piece
like takes takes and then checkmate
that's a fairy move you play Pawn F4
104 looks reasonable
covering G5
now castling
I don't really care about this Pawn even
though that's the base of the pawn chain
um
like Knight G4
how to do this
I also have takes
okay let's go full bananas
Rook H6 coming
there's such a funny line
not sure if it works though
I'm calculating uh this this this and
then this and then oh no my queen and
then checkmate
I'm just realizing that most of the
gamuts is suggested were for white
I need some black habits too maybe after
this game
I'll uh
I'll have it generate a list
all right let's play this move
so I'm down two minor pieces
that I have strong Rooks supposedly
G4 is multi-purpose obviously I'm
attacking this but I'm also
bringing the way for the queen
yeah Knight B4 provokes
between H2
thank you senseless lyrics
hi Eric
all right I'm beginning to win back
material
the rook and queen are in danger
I feel kind of bad that Soul tie may
have been peer pressure to play into
this Gambit but
uh it's good for content
and chat CPT is my uh
is maybe my newly hired chess coach
foreign
[Music]
okay
all right before I move on to the next
game let me bring up Chachi PT
uh please give me a list of rare gambits
for black to play in a blitz S3
a lafian Budapest grub wait grob I could
play the Borg which is G5
nimsovich
okay Blackburn's shilling
all right this is a fine list let's move
on
I feel well equipped with uh
tricky and maybe some made-up gambits
the extension wants me to berserve but
I'm not going to berserk here
let's play the Blackburn shilling
oh I can't play it
can I play the reverse goose
I'm gonna play the reverse Goose which
is G6
we saw this from the white side Four
Knights with G3
um this isn't quite a four nights but
it's half of four nights
at least so far
we can call it the Moose yeah
97.
there's actually an interesting setup
this is not something I would usually
play
but um I think it leads to some Harmony
there's an idea to play Knight A5 and
get rid of this bishop
yeah the bishop can run but they can't
really hide
um
okay how to develop here
between each or
I need to achieve the V shape
we need to play F5 and then the pawns
are kind of like a V
they're kind of like a trapezoid
but it it has to resemble a goose kind
of flying or group of geese
what do you call it a gaggle
gaggle of geese
and trade I guess we can trade
on a five
of the bishop here
hey thankfully there's this move
otherwise Pawn would be in danger
uh
okay at this point I'm just kind of on
my own
out of the opening stage
now this is the only open file so I'd
like to
double up if possible
I'd also like to keep the bishop pair
but that's kind of hard to do
um
tactics don't work
I get the chance I want to play King G7
Pawn H6
chase away the bishop
and then put the Rook back
wow
I mean there's C6
I can also take and play Bishop C6
maybe this is um a bit more active
Pawn is still defended Bishop now has
some life
look at this move
wow what is this move
I mean there's Bishop E4
I'm a little bit flustered here
I think I'll try and trade one pair of
Rooks
in here
so Rook D6 I have Rook C8
and pawns are vulnerable
yeah so I can win this
yeah my pawns want to migrate North for
the time scramble
maybe the pawns can form a v-shape as
they migrate down the board
wait what
oh wow
okay but thankfully it's not meat
but it's not pleasant
clutch Bishop
the backwards v shave
okay
oh that move came out of nowhere Bishop
d8
the bishop V6 was not a good move
and to give the the king some breathing
room
all right that was very fortunate
so we've had a
we had the Eric Rosen Gaba and the
the reverse Goose canvas
again this was a the list
grab suggested
I could play a grab
what's the other one
oh the Penguin game let's try the
penguin gamut
they gave a bunch of E4 gambits as well
okay we'll play amora
also known as the Smith Mora
I don't know so much Theory here but I
know this is generally the setup
and there's ideas with Knight D5
let's go in right away
it's a very thematic idea for the Mora
open the E file especially if I get a
pawn in D5 there's ideas of Rook E1 and
then D6
um I'm just going to Leave the Night On
D5 yeah this should really be called the
Astro Moon
Mark has done the most amount of
research in this this opening
all right so I'm down the piece
but kind of used to that at this point
I want to play rookie one
or D6
Bishop moves back I have rookie one
check
of
let's take and then play Bishop D6
I won back the piece and now winning a
little bit more
oh who's Esserman Esserman is a fellow
chat streamer also International master
he has a book called Mayhem in the Mora
and
yeah it's all about like deep theory in
the opening that I just played
he's being countless GMS with uh the
Smith Mora
and he streams on a pretty regular basis
on Twitch
also very very strong tennis player
you're probably out of all the
international Masters he's a best tennis
player
all right so
play this move first
I want to control the files
I have this move
I'm pinning the bishop
along the rink
if Rook see it I take in the rook and
Bishop are still targets
C7
and now The Bishop's defend it but it's
still pinned so
generally the plan when there is a PIN
to piece you should just attack it as
much as possible
it's also important not to get mated
play G
3 Queen H6 wow
be F4
not the first move that came to mind
I guess there's still Queen H6 but then
I have H3
this and this are attacked
and Bishop here the queen hits my queen
but then I have Queen C8
okay that's a nice finish
I'm more a success
so I'm doing my best to only play
openings at chat GPT told me to play
um and it I have a lot of responses we
had the list of white gambits
here oh I'm playing Solitaire again
and the list of black gambits was here
so I guess I'll try a Blackburn shilling
soul ties in first place after
that first game
the Blackburn Shilling is this uh famous
One Bishop C4 Knight T4
King E2
what do I even play against this
uh I guess I still go for a Blackburn
showing
or not let's let's play the um
uh altered lot viewing gambits
and I sack my queen somehow probably not
I'm not gonna do the bong Cloud copycats
as much as I am tempted
I imagine chat GPT would like warn me
against a bang clown
probably like inappropriate and
unethical
after this game I'll ask its thoughts on
the bond cloud
might is actually like decently solid
here
but I'm a little bit more solid probably
okay and just push everything in the
center
uh so I keep pushing things
give this move
okay no mercy at this point
so I'll have to be a little bit careful
but Queen F4 and
okay there's Queen A4 Knight C6
I'm tempted to Sock the Knight though
your takes here
trying to calculate
ah let's just move back
because this supports Bishop A5 check
uh the knight's coming to D3
all right so I'm gonna Chuck the pawn
probably like King C2 D3 and then
I'll eventually have Knights D4
maybe maybe not
okay still talking the pawn
it's like Moses crossing the
Red Sea
and yeah the point is now the Knight is
pinned the D file's open I have the
square to work with
my Bishop's not getting trapped
the queen is infiltrating
ooh
but is my queen getting trapped
Knight before King D1 wow
I could take on D3 ticks takes
okay someone caught an ambulance
I'm not sure for who yet but for someone
Rook d8 Knight T4
[Music]
I'm I've given up my queen
but White's already given up
um
respect for me by playing the bong alone
seems like a fair trade
okay I want to play this move I feel
like the bishop would be really useful
in supporting the Rooks
uh there's also
[Music]
a knight D4
not seeing it okay let's start with this
Rook is going on a journey
it's painting the bishop 20 months is
more than 19. you Phillip Sharp
Lance is my Bishop in a nice Square
Force hanging
A2 is now attacked
by one dock the queen
down a little bit of time
oh nice move
if I took there would be tactics
oh that was really close
oh
it all started with a bomb cloud and now
we're here
what do you think of
upon Cloud opening
oh can provide an objective analysis
now the sound opening but can be fun and
amusing
I hope people are amused and having fun
all right back to tournament yeah so for
everyone just joining I try to have it
come up with new openings
at the beginning of the Stream
and they came up with like one like
interesting one which I played the first
game of this tournament
um but I also had it like generate a
list of gadgets
so I'm gonna try and play the the
Blackburn Shilling is one of the lines
it recommended
um with this
uh let's play F5
like um inspired by a a king's Gambit
basically
I'm I'm again playing the person in
first place
Sapphire Gambit was not on the list
unfortunately
who knows after this tournament
um okay
just try and be solid here
I think eventually I want to play F4
this is looking Pleasant
and this is kind of the dream for when
you play F5 you get the structure in
White's Castle
and lead to some nice attacking options
and I'm trying to induce this move which
yeah white had to do
and now the G files open
um
there's a lot of avenues of attack
but still requires to have some
attacking plan I'm probably threatening
this move
I was hoping for some Knight F3 idea but
probably have to be patient
or like Queen D7
I really want to double up Rooks on the
G file but
all these squares are controlled by
White's pieces
mainly the minor pieces
G3 is probably a good move
how about I play this
I'm dreaming of someday getting the
queen to H3
I feel like could lead to good things
maybe also enabling Pawn F3
white plays upon F3
well now I have Rook G1 The Rook is a
target
thinking Rook g196
and the pawn is pinned to The Rook
if Rook moves away I take and win the
pawn
I think this is working out nicely
oh but my Bishop's getting stuck
but it's not fully trapped
playing B5 to enable this
still eyeing this G1 Square
yeah the funny thing is that Bishop
can't really move but it can't really be
attacked either
like the queen can't really come in like
like to come to G3 and the pawn digs G3
and that's the same situation with
White's Bishop like I want to attack it
but I can't really do it without losing
something
a weird position
I'm trying to formulate a plan
I'm thinking maybe Rook here sack and
then Queen H7
start with this
I'm threatening to take and take
if I took them Pawn would take
white socking piece
probably a good practical decision
[Music]
um
be really careful here
oh I'm careful enough
and coming in
that was a bad move
no
oh
I thought I was breaking through with A3
but the king's close enough
I should not have given the knights
still played this move
what to do well played
I was the person in first place to
I blame it on chat GPT
where's my
where is it this one is this one
um
what rare move should I play on move one
and seconds
E3
each okay I'm playing A3
oh the Anderson's opening well how about
reverse England Gambit how about
reverse Carol Khan
or Carol Khan but down a tempo
and got to play B4
wow
I'm already a little bit baffled
I think I can play this move
wait a minute
no let's play this move first and then
this move
the problem is G6 leaves a rook
undefended then I have Queen E7
essentially winning The Rook
wow this this opening is actually
working out great
all thanks to a3b4
like a new opening trap
let's go winning with A3 and 8 moves
uh okay
uh let's let's go again
[Music]
what crazy rare opening should I play
with black
uncommon non-traditional the hammer
schlag
wait that's for white though
the Saint George
let's play The Accelerated Saint George
Saint George's Asics accelerates St
George's E5
okay
how are all my opponents in first place
also what to do here okay for that was
an amazing win
oh thank you Gabriel
all right
uh G5
this is very non-traditional chess
okay
so I'm basically trying to justify like
the weird moves
um
uh
it's a slightly annoying move
how to deal with this
night here
I give the Rook some Mobility
D4 blocks the bishop
a foreign
I'm self-pinning for the wind just like
ding
although this probably isn't comparable
to ding's Rook G6
but it is making my opponent think we
might see this move
or that move
so G3 is met with F4 it's very very
clever
start with E6
Queen G5
this is such a mess
okay that was a fair trade
of this bishop
it's actually a reasonable position like
the Rooks are happy where they are
the Knight will come in the king is
actually pretty safe in the center
do I want to trade Queens
probably
maybe not
in E5
I mean my pawns should be on darkspurs
okay let's check
that worked out well
the Knight wants to come to E3
so there's a plan of this
and it's kind of working out
now it's actually a difficult position
for white like these pieces aren't
really
that active
and the plan is just so clear for black
hard to develop the bishop as well
like all the pawns are pretty much stuck
yeah if only the Knight could teleport
moving one big L
I think it's understandable why White's
thinking here it's really hard to find a
productive move Queen D2 would lose a
pawn
oh that's a move
okay
I prevented the plan of Rook F3 but
white did it anyway
all right I'm still making my way to the
promised land
see this
I just push upon
oh no my Rook
about a queen almost
back
what is this
I mean obviously I have one Queen but
E5 is not even legal and T5
every too late it's a castle
my Rook was attacked this Castle oh I
have this move though
let's check
and let's play this move
I have two pawns about to Queen
Knight's pinned
It Feels Like These are on imposter
ponds like usually these are white pawns
but
it changed color
all right that was a weird game that was
probably like the weirdest opening
but we'll keep it going
what else did it say
oh the next Tango
that's a fun one
defense
um what was the Gambit that it made up
the penguin
the penguin attack
E5 and then
all right we have whatever this is
um
it didn't give me anything for the Karo
Khan so I'll play uh I'll make up a
canvas of my own E3 Bishop B2
there is a similar Gambit against the
French
it goes exactly like this
and it's actually interesting
development
double feeding cattle
white is temporarily down the pond but
this Pawn should be winnable
um trying to drop the bishop
I want back the pawn
this night is a little bit pesky like
but it's also undefended
maybe I'll go for 92.
interesting
D3
there's Bishop B4 and then I'll decide
between King F1 or C3
getting some decent piece Harmony now
uh that prevents me from castling
I think now is probably a decent time to
trade Queens
all right delayed banglad
the block avoids the queen trade my king
is a little bit silly
but the pawn on G7 is hanging so
black probably has to take and then
defend the pawn
if casting I have Knight G3
and this Pawn can't really be defended
yeah this actually looks really nice
because I'm gonna win the pawn
and then there will be some attack
and my Rook can swing to G1
start with A3 B4
just close down the queen side
probably the plan is to play
let's start with B5
do this this and then push the H Pawn
black is playing in a good practical
manner like trying to
stir up counter play
Knight B3 King D1
all right this is a fork
I don't think I want to take that
I think I just want to go after the king
there's a funny line assuming the Rook
move that I have G6 H6
which looks pretty overwhelming for Bach
wait a minute
D3 King E1
rookie 3 King F2 and then there's no
more checks
what's happening
back there okay this is a fork
I'm really tempted to play this but
a free rook
okay should be in good shape here
after all said and done I'm up a rook
for two Pawns
throw in the check
the goal is to win this Rook
the king is tied down
and now it's forced away
there's a funny move Knight A6
it just after it takes takes upon is
very strong
okay
am I within range of winning the
tournament probably not
soul ties on a rampage
11 minutes left
if I want to try and win the tournament
I probably berserk
probably have to berserk
well okay what to play next Owen defense
oh let's play the night Tango
oops
hey not quite playing the night Tango
here
uh let's go back or let's uh oh yeah
let's go back
I was too slow to berserk there
and now we're tangling with the Knights
and guite was dreaming of Queen E2 in
Knight T6 smothered checkmate
I think they just missed that the night
was attacked
um
and being safe
and the dream is to do this like
eventually Knight G3 and H takes G3
getting closer
I'm playing in a style to try and win as
quickly as possible
I'll see if it works out oh my Bishop
oh no
someone can't ambulance
but not for me
it's a funny mating idea
I like white has three blocking moves
okay
oh the dream plan worked out
I mean when I played Bishop C5 I was
already like trying to
imagine how it could work out
it's a very typical uh mating motif
okay
13 points behind
still refreshing what does a hammer
schlatting
so it's a four knights with G4 okay
actually looks kind of cool I I haven't
seen that one before
but we have a scandi instead
at some point I mentioned the BlackMart
Deemer
which is we're playing
um play this
yeah BlackMart dimmer it's uh
it's a pretty classic Gambit
I've sacked the F Pawn
um
I know this is one of the ideas it might
backfire
but just to expand
on the king side
kind of similar to what you sometimes
see in Joe Bava London
it's risky because my king is like
completely naked
uh he I might be regretting this
Bishop H4
okay I was more scared of Bishop H4
Knight G3
I might as well Castle
it's legal to Castle when the Rooks
attacked just not when the Kings
attacked
keeping this bishop
I do want to attack on the king side
I already have the pawn storm in place
I had to defend D4
Queen G5 comes
I think I'll play this move
the idea is of takes I play Rook F5
and try and um
disturb the queen
oh I forgot about the room
[Music]
um
not too much hope here
I need a miracle to survive
aha
I was hoping for some still me trap what
to do though
all right
um I still want to play that penguin
Gambit
but we're not quite getting it
so be aggressive
each Pond thrust
what happens with berserk's stalemate
wait did I miss mate into the previous
game
I'm trying to think back
there is a moment where I had like Queen
E8 but there is a bishop on C6 defending
e8s
oh the opponent had yeah the opponent
had many mates
okay
um
let's try and keep the pressure here
a knight doesn't have too many squares
oh this might be the last game that
counts for the tournament
oh try and make accounts as much as
possible
so I'm attacking the knight from a
distance
um
at this point it's probably a matter of
just completing development
trying to strike in some way
threatening to take the Knight
yeah because the bishop is pinned to the
queen
how good is Chad GPT openings
um I mean it gave a list of like a lot
of common openings and then it kind of
struggled when it came to coming up with
like brand new openings
but at least we got a few like
interesting ideas
I still want to look into the hammer
schlag
like four nights with G4
and the opening that it suggested that I
played in the first game of this
tournament was probably the best one
like it was a tricky Gambit but had a
ton of compensation
okay this game should count for the
tournament
oh no my queen
I think this is a like it was the most
efficient Force mate Queen h8
let me um let me just verify that
yeah Queen h8 made in three
okay
bearings are closed
the tournament is finished congrats to
sultai
yeah I played Soul tie a couple of games
the first game it was uh
will charge EPT opening
um which Chachi BT called it the the
Eric Rosen Gambit
this is probably one of the
the highlights of the tournament this H4
move
anyway
um tournament's over that was fun I'll
probably put the whole tournament on
YouTube